الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي مع كذلك من
روما
الامين العام السابق لحلف جمال الاطلسي
اهلا بكم ما ابدا معك سيد
كيف يمكن قراءه دلالات هذا التصعيد
العسكري ما بين على الحدود البيلاروسيه
بين موسكو والجناح الشرقي لحلف النيتو كيف
يمكن ان نفسره الان ودلالات هذا التصعيد
العسكري
لا اعتقد اننا نتحدث عن خطر
عسكري حقيقي هناك
سياسيه خارجه من بولندا ومن الدول في
منطقه البلطيق لانه من المنظور العسكري
هنا في روسيا ليس لدينا اي تعزيز القوات
المسلحه وايضا في بيلاروسيا التحركات
الطبيعيه هناك انتقال لمجموعه فاكنر بين
المنطقتين نتحدث عن
تدريب من دون اي خطوات عسكريه او تصعيدا
عسكريا حقيقي
طيب سيد
اليساندو بينوتو هل هل توافق هذا الكلام
تحدث به السيد
بان لا تصعيد عسكري من قبل روسيا او
بيلاروسيا وانما هي خطوات اعتياديه وهناك
تدريب لتلك القوات على الحدود
كلا لا اتفق ولسوء الحظ مع ما قاله الضيف
الاخر حيث ان الامر يرتبط بالبروباغاندا
والدعايه الاعلاميه نعم هذا صحيح هناك حرب
نفسيه وانا اتفق بالنسبه الى هذا الموضوع
اذا الان ليس
التصعيد هو المساله الاساسيه ولكن الرئيس
البيلاروسي منذ ايام قليله تحدث عن حوالي
200 شخص من مجموعه فاغنر يتوجهون الى
المنطقه وبالتالي وبكل تاكيد نحن لا نتحدث
عن ازمه عسكريه طبعا 100 شخص لا يمكنهم ان
يجتاحوا بولندا ولكن من جهه اخرى هناك
غياب في الثقه هناك غياب في الثقه ينظر كل
طرف الى الطرف الاخر بشكل عدائي ولذلك
بولندا ت ان تتاكد من ان لكن يعني
حشد اكثر من 300 الف جندي على الحدود مع
بيلاروسيا يعني كيف يمكن ان تردوا على مثل
هذه الاتهامات وكيف يمكن ان نفهم مثل هذه
التعزيزات اذا كانت فقط 200
عضو او فرد من فاجنر هم الذين يتوجهون الى
تلك الحدود تلك المنطقه
حسنا حسنا اذا اجابتي عن سؤالك بالنسبه
الى خطواتي الحكومه البولنديه كنت اقول ان
الحكومه البولنديه تود ان تثبت لشعبها ان
بولندا دوله قويه وهي لا تخشى الحرب طبعا
لا نتحدث عن حرب او مواجهه وشيكا او
احتكاك وشيك مع مجموعه
ولكن طبعا هناك انباء
بعدما قاله الرئيس البيلاروسي بادهم اتي
عنصر من يتجهون نحو الحدود اذن هذا هذا ما
ادى الى تلك النتيجه ورد الفعل وانا اود
ان لا اتفق مجددا ايضا مع الضيف الروسي كل
شيء بدا
بالاعتداء الروسي كل ما نراه الان نتيجه
الاعتداء الروسي طيب اذا كل شيء نراه الان
هو نتيجه الاعتد
اء بحشتها هذه القوه الكبيره على الحدود
مع بيلاروسيا تقول انت انت تقول بان لا
حاجت هناك ولا اي خطوات من هذا النوع لكن
هي التي اليوم تقول بان هناك حشود من قبل
حلف النيتو ما الذي يمكن ان تتعامل معه او
او يعني ترد به موسكو على هذه الحشود
اود ان اضيف في حقيقه الامر انه ليس فقط
بولندا بل ايضا فنلندا ذكرت لانه وفقا
لوزاره الدفاع الروسيه ايضا فنلندا حشدت
القوات الاضافيه بالاضافه الى قدرات
الصاروخيه هناك اذا المشكله هي في جانب
حلف شمال الاطلسي هو من يعزز القدرات
العسكريه في الجناح الشرقي وهذا ما يجب ان
اتذكره بالاضافه الى ذلك وفقا للرئيس
بوتين
واستخبارات
الروسيه هناك محاوله الدخول الى غرب
اوكرانيا من قبل بولندا لربما هذه القوات
يمكن ان تدخل الى اوكرانيا كخطوه اضافيه
في المستقبل لذلك روسيا تاخذ هذا الاحتمال
بعد
كيف يمكن ان تتعامل موسكو مع هذا التحشيد
وهذا التعزيز
لقوات النيتو على تلك الحدود
اعتقد ان
نرى ردا عسكريا
حقيقيا لان
تواجد العسكري في بيلاروسيا من قبل القوات
البيلاروسيه والقوات الروسيه مناسب في
الفتره الراهنه
وليس هناك حاجه
لتعزيز هذا التواجد لربما اذا ما استمرت
بولندا بارسال جنود اضافيين تعزز روسيا
التواجد هناك
ريزو ما الذي
يعني ادتنا بوضوح اكثر وتفصيل اكثر ما
الذي يتخوف منه حلف الناتو والذي ادى الى
ارسال مثل هذه الحشود الى الحدود ما هي
السيناريوهات التي
تقلق النيتو في هذه المرحله
هناك الكثير من
التصريحات
والبيانات ولكن لا اعتقد ان بولندا سوف
تدخل الى اوكرانيا انا لا ارى هذا الموضوع
وقد ذكره الضيف الاخر اذا حقيقه ان روسيا
تود ان تخاطب الراي العام الروسي وتقول ان
حلف شمال الافاصيل هو الجهه العدائيه ولكن
الحقيقه هي انهما من احدا يود ان يعتدي
على روسيا ودوله في خلف النيتو لن تدخل
اوكرانيا هذا جزء من الحملات الدعائيه
نحن لا نتحدث عن امر وشيك نتحدث عن بلد
مسالم وهو اوكرانيا اجتاحته روسيا في
الثاني والعشرين من فبراير مشروبات وهذا
ادى الى
النتائج التي رايناها طبعا هناك مخاوف
هناك مخاوف بعد هذا الاعتداء من قبل
الدوله عظمى الا وهي روسيا ولكن الان
النيتو ليس لديه اينيه بالاعتداء لا على
بيلاروسيا ولا على روسيا كل ذلك جزء من
البروباجندا الرئاسيه الروسيه
نائب الامين العام السابق لحلف في شمال
الاطلسي وشكرا لك ان ريفا الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي من موسكو